that's your cue
clay
it's time to go on but i see no signs of
life
nothing but an empty cave
clay
it's okay
just sing
your songs will carry you no
this is a mistake please
it's been so long
i'm not ready
i'm sorry
i'm not ready
i have climbed
the highest mountains
i have run
through the fields only to be
with you
only to be with you
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
[Music]
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know i believe is
found
what i'm looking for
but i
still haven't found
what i'm looking
[Music]
hi there i'm pete hammond and i'm here
with scene at the academy where we
examine a specific scene uh from an
upcoming film uh as well as talk about
that movie and i'm really happy here uh
to be with the creators of sing to it's
such a fun uh inspiring movie of course
the sequel to 2016's uh sing
and we're going to talk all about it
here and you just saw uh this incredible
clip there with bono and uh the iconic
uh song from youtube but that's one of
many songs in this so let me welcome
first up a producer head of illumination
so many movies that he's made uh so many
great movies chris milled andre
hi
hello pete how are you and we have
returning he did the first film as well
writer and director garth jennings hi
hello pete how you doing very good very
good
and uh wow you know looking at that clip
there how iconic and what a get as they
say in the business what a get uh to get
bono as part of this uh cast which is
already a great voice cast but
chris as producer i just have to ask you
uh how'd you do it well uh the secret
weapon um was really garth because we
got together and we talked about
ideas um who could play this character
and
um and as we just started to discuss it
it just we just kept coming back to bono
as our dream casting
um and um and and what we did it was
really sent garth in
to talk to him and really share what his
vision was for the film for the
character
um and bono was quite you know cautious
and deliberate about his process of
determining whether or not this was the
project that he wanted to get involved
with so
um i have to say it was um it was
garth's you know
the time he spent with bono that really
convinced bono that this was a film to
um to to uh to join with us on yeah
garthy's never done an animated feature
like this and uh of course you're able
to get these songs that everybody knows
but you were also able to get how did
this happen you got an original song out
of bono too for the yeah well you know
what actually although chris is being
very generous here saying i was a part
of this and and yes i definitely had a
role in this
but it was really the first film that is
our biggest calling card he really loved
the first film he could see that we
really loved music
and
you know that was clear in the way we've
used it and the way we've worked with it
and he was very vocal about that
and we had this long conversation about
45 minutes it was the initial chat and
honestly by the end of it he was saying
well look this is a story about grief
this is about
how this music would bring this
character back
there is a song in this
and he literally said it as a suggestion
like i think there's a song in this we
never went asking for an original song
we always had the uh the original uh the
old songs from you two in mind and um
and we talked about what that song would
be
but i thought he was talking
hypothetically and i wasn't going to
hold him to it
and it wasn't until we got into the
studio to record his first few lines of
dialogue
that he then turned around afterwards
and said oh by the way i wrote that song
and um
because he felt so passionate about it
not just in terms of how it would work
for the character in the film but it's
also very much how he feels about music
it really did in his in his words save
his life so he felt it it felt very
moved to write this piece of music and
uh
and i i am still astounded that i'm even
able to talk about it in this way that
this was a gift that you just never get
normally and we saw in this scene and
you know you see it at his portion of
the movie as well he's a recluse uh his
wife had died he's out of the business
and they lure him back and this is an
exciting moment in the film here where
he's walking on stage there with ash and
there and they're doing this and it's
back to show business and it's and it's
kind of everything and it's beautifully
staged can you guys talk about that that
moment and using that great song
too
well first of all it's of course it's
super quiet
it starts with nothing because he's just
can't cross that threshold
uh it's it's too much he's been 15 years
uh away from this at this point in his
this this part of himself and it's a
terrifying prospect for him so i love
the fact that it just becomes this very
quiet very still the camera doesn't even
move and it's just very much about him
um
just being stuck in this this this this
this moment and it's ash connecting with
the audience and that love from the
audience
coming back by singing his song back to
him that that brings him out and it's
you know it's all there that his whole
story is there that coming down the you
know the cave
out into the light you know um it's all
in a way an illustration of his entire
process
um he's literally going from the dark
into the light and the crowds are all
there waiting for him welcoming him back
with music
and by the end of it of course
just beyond this clip he's literally
floating on air by the end of it he
floats up above the audience he's he's
lifted up as it transcends the whole
thing so you really do get to hopefully
feel
an emotional sort of
how he's going through this emotionally
yeah chris that's so important to you in
your films too the emotional element the
characters the content the story content
that i think that drives everything
illumination does and of course the
humor too uh but uh those those story
elements those elements are really
important to get those in these films
yeah i think you know for us it really
starts with character and trying to find
that sort of honest place inside of each
character
that perhaps has
insecurity or
fear or
um
you know really kind of rooting
ourselves in
um in in in the flaws of a character as
well as
the dreams of a character and for me
that sequence um
as as garth was describing it to me it
it so speaks to
really
what we aspire to um to to to have a
scene
that can communicate as much as this one
scene does
and i just marvel at the performance the
animation performance that garth and the
animation directors and co-directors
brought to
to life there
with
the that that you can so feel
that
that trepidation
in in
the clay callaway's character as he
begins to walk down that that that that
that ramp to the to the stage
and um and and i think if you look at
garth's direction in in the movie of
clay to me it's it's one of the most
nuanced
animated performances
um
that we've certainly had in any of our
films
there's so much that's done with so
little um and you really feel
bono's voice so inhabiting that
character and that moment
yeah it's it's amazing you know what
else i noticed too in this scene is the
quality the costumes the production
design all of that stuff you don't
necessarily automatically think in
animation but it's just as important in
animation as it is in live action films
and it's really very uh front and center
here garth
yeah i mean you can't
we were promising our audience a big
show at the end the kind of scale that
you might find in on a big big stage in
vegas
and um and even though our characters
have humble beginnings they had to feel
like they own each one of those moments
and so yeah we we didn't we didn't mess
about that we went straight to like um
we hooked up for instance in terms of
costumes with data who are brilliant
fashion designers and were able to sort
of
sort of bring that skill set and that
that that amazing sort of attention to
detail they have to to all of our
characters so they weren't just fabulous
costumes they really were telling the
story so you know mina who's sort of
suddenly falling in love and it's just
this great big flowing romantic dress
that all it all sort of adds to that and
the same with ash that she is literally
light she is filled with microfibers and
these little leds and things that will
just everything reflects and she's
literally this little shining light in
his life and he's
coming out he just has to come out
feeling like an authentic
rock legend you have to think there you
know there he is he's back as you last
saw him you know so it's real rocks you
know rock star kind of outfits but again
like perfectly executed by rodate and
the same for the set designs they had to
feel like they were they weren't just
beautiful but they were serving that
emotional purpose
um that that that you know that he was
gonna have to come out of a cave he was
gonna have to come out into the light
and at the end float up into the air um
i love that we were able to
illustrate these emotional stories that
way yeah i i watch that sequence and
um the entire sort of third act of the
movie and all i think about is wanting
to see garth direct for the stage
because you just
you sit back and you think about
just performance and color and light and
music
all coming together in this
fantastic show
um
and i just find myself wanting to
actually see that show or show like that
coming out of garth's imagination
actually sitting in a theater live well
you know maybe you're going to give us a
little scoop here i mean sing could i
could easily see this on a broadway
stage
let's do it let's decide that right now
right
you know chris you came up with this
idea 10 years ago however long it was
and and and got it into motion and um
you know what was it you know shows like
american idol and the voice were showing
people following their dreams and the
first thing was was definitely about
buster moon following a dream this one i
think is how far can you take that dream
and and and how much do you believe in
yourself and your ultimate potential too
i think that was
that's absolutely you know clearly
central to it where i started with it
was this idea
of
um
of
actually producing which is you have
ideas
and you ha and they're just ideas and
you want them to ultimately manifest
into
this
you know huge production and as you
communicate those ideas
you
have to believe in them
to a degree where at some point are you
just sharing your thoughts are you
starting to cross the line and
actually
being somewhat fraudulent in the sense
that it's going to be great it's going
to be the big but you have nothing but
an idea
and i this
this kind of story and character had
been kicking around my head for quite
some time
and
i saw
garth's movie son of rambo which is not
an animated movie
um it's it's it's this absolute gem of a
film a pure character piece
and um and and it just stuck with me the
humanity in it and it so at some point i
realized that
this was my partner to set out on this
journey and what was interesting is as
as
in my head buster started off from the
perspective of a producer but the minute
that garth became involved he got so
much
more um
kind of um
he became he became far more legitimate
you know i was thinking just
purely from you know the razzle dazzle
of a producer and garth sort of was
bringing
the spirit of a director but what we
found was that that in both cases
there is this moment where you're
sharing your ideas about something
and you have to get everybody to believe
in them and you yourself
um are filled with doubt so what do you
do with that doubt um and
and you're asking people to have faith
and and that's kind of where this that
journey started for us well who knew
this was the chris mellodondry story uh
you know
[Laughter]
it was for five minutes until it became
the garth jennings story
no i think that's the thing chris and i
have identified with this character all
the way along i think that's why it's
been a joy we've sort of channeled
ourselves into this thing and uh and
then it doesn't hurt to have someone
like matthew mcconaughey who gives this
sort of colorful
take on this this sort of it makes this
character so endearing
and yet so you know such a pickle he
remains a pickle throughout
but
but no i think you're right i remember
when you talked about those things when
we first met about this chris just over
10 years ago
instantly i was like oh yeah i
completely could see where you were
going
and like you said we didn't know where
it was going we just sort of believed
that that road would lead us here who
knew who would end up here 10 years
later
well you know and it's amazing and uh
what a a gift for uh families uh to see
this and it has so many great elements
you mentioned matthew mcconaughey of
course reece witherspoon scarlett
johansson uh you can go on and on tara
and edgerton and then halsey you've got
in this and pharrell williams and i mean
what a cast it's an amazing thing to put
together and i want to thank both of you
uh for uh telling us the secrets behind
this and and uh and sharing this with
scene at the academy today thank thanks
chris and thanks garth
thank you